Géraldine donc inaugure avec nous et
bien cette collaboration avec l'Institut
national de l'audiovisuel et qui va nous
permettre d'éclairer certaines sujets
par des archives et sur ce sujet du
harcèlement scolaire
Géraldine a une archive que je connais
que j'ai déjà vu et que je trouve assez
forte ça c'est une archive que qui date
donc de 809 alors le mot harcèlement
n'est à aucune aucun moment n'hésitez
pas
je vous laisse voir mais donc c'est une
archi qui date de 89 c'est un programme
qui s'appelait c'est pas juste alors moi
je ne connaissais pas et grâce à Lina on
redécouvre ses programmes de Vincent
Perrault de Vincent Perrot c'est marrant
France 3 et en fait l'idée de ce
programme là c'est que c'était souvent
des enfants qui interpellaient en disant
il m'arrive ça c'est pas juste et donc
là c'est l'histoire de Sarah qui a 12
ans en 89 et qui dit qu'on l'embête à
l'école et que c'est pas juste je
m'appelle Sarah j'ai 12 ans
j'habite à Strasbourg et à l'école et
dans la rue on mettra des saletés et de
caméléons et je trouve que c'est injuste
ça a commencé quand je suis arrivée au
collège
des garçons de 5e
et 5e ou Traité de sa tête puis ça a
duré toute l'année et puis
en 5e un garçon qui
qui est venu dans ma classe qui a
commencé de me traiter de caméléon
de temps en temps
non ils ont commencé je l'ai déjà je les
connaissais pas ils vont commencer je
les ai jamais provoqué
[Musique]
je sais pas si vous avez entendu la
journée en fait elle essaie de
comprendre si c'était pas un peu de la
France
et donc ça c'est la partie reportage et
ensuite il y a un plateau parce que les
missions voilà c'est une émission qui
durait qui durait longtemps et en
plateau donc il y a cette Sarah qui a 12
ans il y a sa maîtresse enfin sa prof il
y a une copine à elle et il y a les
élèves on dirait aujourd'hui harceleur
ah oui son plateau et
ce qui est intéressant c'est que
l'équipe Youtube de Lina qui est une
équipe formidable et je leur fais un
gros gros coucou voilà dédicace on
retrouvait cette Sarah 35 ans plus tard
donc aujourd'hui c'est une mère de
famille elle a trois enfants elle a vu
l'archive et elle explique en fait que
c'est elle qui avait demandé à ce que
ses élèves harceleurs qui se moquaient
d'elle donc caméléon sale tête soit sur
le plateau et ce qui est hallucinant
c'est que sur le plateau Vincent Perrot
dit par exemple bah voilà elle a un
petit problème du quotidien
et c'est que ça et vraiment toutes les
missions est affligeantes je vous
conseille du coup d'aller voir leur
portage de YouTube ou Sarah aujourd'hui
regarde ça et les enfants de Sarah
réagissent en disant mais maintenant
ils disent mais en fait notre maman est
super forte parce que elle affronte
aujourd'hui ce qu'on pourrait appeler
donc qui sont pas du tout nommés comme
ça dans le sujet et aujourd'hui cette
dame et ben elle va bien et le reportage
donc on fait mes collègues de Lina est
très beau parce que ça se termine avec
plein d'espoir en disant que au final
même si elle avait pas du coup pris
conscience que elle était victime de
harcèlement parce que c'était des
injures et des moqueries répétées tous
les jours donc si c'est pas la
définition du harcèlement je sais pas ce
que c'est
mais du coup elle elle dit
qu'aujourd'hui elle prend conscience
avec son œil d'adulte qu'elle a été
victime d'harcèlement et qu'elle
souhaite pour tous les enfants en fait
de ne pas le taire de d'en parler
regarde de joie retrouver
je vous conseille d'aller le voir
tu te dis bon voilà tu prends aussi la
porte de chez toi tu penses tu es avec
tes parents tu es voilà sécurité et en
fait ça ça revient chez toi tu peux
avoir une conversation à l'époque
c'était MSN Messenger qui va s'ouvrir et
on va voir marquer sale con quoi le
progrès c'est que le mot aujourd'hui il
est posé et que la société on parle que
les médias on parle que les politiques
on parle et prennent des décisions c'est
pas encore assez efficace mais oui vous
avez oublié effectivement le côté
réseaux sociaux qui fait qu'en fait sur
harcèlement il s'arrête plus à la porte
de l'école quoi